we've had this interesting moment in
history where Tolkien who is a devout
Christian created a fantasy world
developed a fantasy Trope in a way that
was based on pre-christian and Pagan and
folk elements so what we're trying to do
is push that in a direction that will
surprise everyone bringing in tropes of
Christian iconography not explicitly but
you know the way the story is told the
way that the layout is done and so here
of course we have an image which is you
know basically the image of Constantine
and Helen standing together but that is
also joined with a kind of Adam Adam and
Eve image with the tree in the center
and so really bringing in different
images from the Christian tradition but
to bring them in a way that most people
won't know like if someone looks at this
they'll just they'll just see it they
won't necessarily understand what we're
dragging into it but that is what that's
what we're bringing into the image a
Christian dream world that is exactly
what we're going for
thank you